hello everybody welcome to another
YouTube hang out super pumped to be here
with you I have a special episode today
we're doing a podcast interview my guess
is jane wang from the inner changemaker
podcast we've linked it up in the
description below so go check that out
jay is going to be interviewing me for
his podcast and we're doing a live
stream here to youtube so he's going to
run with it and ask me his questions
talk about his show bit and I'm excited
so Jay men welcome aboard and let's get
into it yeah well Evan thank you so much
for the opportunity totally honored to
be here and just chatting with you and
so thank you for taking the time to do
this because I know you know there's so
much going on on your side of things and
when I was telling people that I was
having edvin on it's actually really
funny because I was just watching your
interview of grant and grant was on
yesterday and we had a really great time
but Evan when people think about you or
at least for me I see you put out so
much content right you have all these
top 10 Lissa's you have all the vlogs
now you have the book going on the
flitter Lee the first thing that came to
my mind was how do you how do you not
get caught in the consuming content type
of like hamster wheel where you're just
constantly consuming things and you're
not actually applying them in your lives
and this is this goes for YouTube stuff
this goes for podcasting how do you deal
with you know consuming so much content
and still being able to apply that in
your life and in your business you look
for my audience how to make sure that
they actually do the work and not just
watch all the videos or me well I you
personally got it okay uh yeah it's a
big deal I also think that personal
development is important and and how I
do it is I make time for it so I am NOT
here's an example okay a buddy of mine
Alex who helps me run one of my
businesses asked me to sorry I asked him
he's moving yesterday and I asked him
hey do you need help moving you need me
to help move bringing food whatever and
he's like no I appreciate it but if you
want to come by and say hi come on over
like no I don't do say hi
my time is is valuable and not that
that's a waste of time just every second
that I'm spending has to have impact and
so I don't the time that I spend in
consuming content and learning from jobs
or Schultz or Kanye or whoever it is
doing the interviews like you talk with
being prolific this is my eighth live
stream of the day myself another one
after right and we're still going and
we've got energy to burn right but you
know the sacrifices I'm not hanging out
with my friends at the bar or whatever
right like I don't know just chill out
time I need my own chill time because
I'm naturally introverted that may not
you know come across in this interview
but apart from that like the time that
I'm spending is either on myself and
recovery or going all-in and what I'm
doing and I think people just waste a
lot of time so if you if you wanna you
want to learn you want to develop you
want to grow uh I think my channel is
one of the best in the world to do it
like will take 20 hours of Elon Musk
footage and condense it down to the best
15 minutes of advice that he's ever
given in the history of Elon Musk on
film film so far you know so far right
and you don't have 15 minutes to watch
that video and apply you kidding me
right leg so I it's for me Ryan do it
substrate for myself because I want the
content I want to learn from these great
people I want them to push me to be the
best version of myself and so I value
the knowledge I value the growth and so
I make time for it and I lose out on
other stuff that I don't you know aren't
as important to me yeah multiple choices
right and clearly you've made you know
some some really great ones I took a
look at some of your just stats like on
your YouTube channel you're like four
hundred twenty-eight thousand like
subscribers like 50-something plus like
million views like take us back a bit
and I understand like some people might
be watching this and they're like well
we ready no Evans story but maybe for
the people that are not too familiar of
like how you got started what was like
the initial motivation for you like why
did you start a YouTube channel I never
I never wanted to be YouTube famous
when I started to was your YouTube
famous like it's a rite of a thing it
wasn't a career to aspire to be I
started because when I had my first
business I sucked I failed I wanted to
quit I told my business partner that I
quit and I just didn't want other
entrepreneurs who have to suffer through
the same crappy feeling that I had to go
through is the lowest point of my life
I've never felt so worthless and useless
at the lowest points of my business and
I didn't have anybody you know I people
ask me on my livestreams we had some
people this morning 13 14 years old
asking questions man I wish I had that
when I was 13 14 unbelievable i'm so
jealous if the opportunity's people have
now uh so i started off just you know
profiling famous entrepreneurs because
their stories that Bill Gates helped
save my business I'd never met him but
his story helps save my business mean
running a software company and
understanding that I'm not the first guy
to try to do this before somebody has
already figured out the model if I can
learn from their success because I
clearly wasn't having any success learn
him that i right quiet to my business
that's when I took the strategy Bill
Gates and we turn the company around and
in three years what from making three
hundred dollars a month to having nasa
and johnson Johnson his clients in 30
countries and eventually selling
business and so I made the channel to
just share some of that knowledge so
that other people other entrepreneurs
wouldn't have to go through the same
kind of suffering that I went through in
my business um and with with time and
picked up you know like it was only me
at the start i'm making one video a
month you know it's it was a slow start
now up to five a day today there's you
know nine uh so I'd look up my team
really but like if you want to be great
of what you do you have to be prolific
you know you got to practice your art ya
know whatever it is you want to be a
painter pick painting once a month isn't
enough you got to hone your skills the
quantity leads to the quality you got to
get better you got to do it more a lot
of the videos I've made haven't even
surface haven't even gone live because
you know they weren't good enough in my
view but you know I deserve what I have
but I also it's a negative and a
positive like you may say hey
you got 400,000 subs that's great and
I'm super proud and grateful of that but
I'm also not at 4 million I don't
deserve that yet I'm not good enough yet
my quality the quality stuff isn't that
good yet right like I gotta still get
better to chase down those dreams so
what do you think personally I mean not
now that you bring this up that you know
for you maybe you know the next kind of
milestone is like getting you know too
that million mark or four million mark
whatever 10 xing um you know you're your
own kind of subscribership like what is
missing do you believe for you guys or
is it just a matter of consistency
because you see a lot of times that a
lot of people there are two podcasts or
they'll start a YouTube show and there's
like well Jay or Evan I only got like 10
views I only got like 50 views i only
got like a hundred views so you know how
do you I guess is a kind of a two-part
question like what do you think you're
missing to kind of get to that next
level and I guess what advice would you
have for people kind of starting out uh
I need to get better you know what's
missing is me I need to be uh if I look
at look at my how I started my channel
look at my energy my thoughts my
comments um it was ok but I've gotten a
lot better you know if you do three and
a half thousand videos you'd hope that
you get a little better at it in the
process right but but you know as good
as I might be right now there's people
who are way better right I'm not Tony
Robbins level or less brown level or the
people that I look up to and I don't
need to be Tony Robbins it's not the
goal but I need to be as good as what
i'm doing this Tony isn't with what he's
doing I'm not LeBron of my thing yet
right I need to get better and we all
have an inner genius look you need to be
the lebron and podcasting write down
what's the best version of jwong right
you've you've got your thing you're
building your growing you know why is
your podcast not ten million subscribers
well you need to get better too right
now so you know I deserve what I have
not put in the work but I also deserve
what I have that I'm not good enough yet
and so I feel like everything it needs
to get better the videos need to get
better the editing needs to get better
the the selection of Clips need to get
better my points need to get better
everything to get better and is a
constant
it's a constant thing right you're never
perfect this always was always room to
improve so it's like the road to mastery
right yeah we're it's just about
consistency and it's about showing up
every day nfo art yet people are in
copying the style right like people out
if you look at the mashups that we're
doing the top ten rules whatever we're
already the best at it right nobody else
is hey you guys wanna name and the
people who are copying us are they're
copying exactly what I'm doing right
there doing the exact same thing that
I'm doing but it's not enough yet like I
gotta push the envelope more there's
still stuff missing and I don't I don't
know exactly what's missing I gotta keep
testing experimenting and seen what it
is because I believe what people saw if
more people saw the videos the world
would be a better place like and more
people listen to your podcast the world
to be a better place and so that's on me
I accept responsibility i need to get
better my team needs to get better if I
if I was just starting up I'm think if
you're attached to views you're never
going to win you have to be attached to
making the videos you have to be like a
good video for me as one I have to feel
it here right I've got a feeling in my
heart it's gotta be something I want to
show you know my seven-year-old son when
he grows up to say like look at what i
did this message is important for you I
think too many people within YouTube or
podcasting or starting the business or
whatever it is they jump in because they
think they could become this huge
superstar but they don't enjoy the work
like if you did not enjoy interviewing
people the podcast is never going to
take off like it just won't right right
now I marry like all the effort you put
in whatever if you're not liking the
work if you're just a notch to the
outcome of I want to have a million
people listening to this or whatever it
is you never you're never gonna get
there you have to enjoy the work and
that's across anything yeah well you
know Evan I i love that you bring that
up we had I think was a Fisher is tucker
max we had him on like a few months back
and he was talking about
very similar concept he was like well GE
says for example he took writing people
that want to be writers write and said
did you which are due are you in love
with the artistry of writing or do you
want to be considered a writer right
because one is you want to be the role
you want to be the entrepreneur you want
to be the writer you want to be you know
youtuber whatever it is without taking
the risk because you just want the
vanity metrics so you want the name or
the notoriety whatever whatever it is
for you right but for the people that
love their artistry for the people that
love solving problems that those are the
best entrepreneurs right for the people
that love writing even if they're broke
those are some of the best writers
overtime right so I love that you bring
that up and I think there's a lot of
truth to that and I hope people you know
actually understood that um you know
I'll tell you really quick before we
move on I watched one of your I think
was a live stream wait okay when you
started like clapping and you're just
like going at it and I was like Evan I'm
digging this right because I think
people want to see like how people get
pumped up to like do these things you
know a lot of people could just think oh
man are they did it just drink a coffee
and they're good to go so it was really
cool to kind of see that so i don't know
maybe incorporate a lot more of the
clapping or behind the scenes stuff that
was an experiment like we're talking
about growth and try that started this
week get started on monday it was me
today yeah i was doing i had to go i'm
doing the audio version of my book and i
had to go down studio and record all day
long from ten o'clock the five o'clock
and so i only had time for my gratitude
live stream in the morning and i had the
rush to get to the studio and it was so
jacked up like I get to finally go it's
been like a year and a half I get to
finally go over court this thing and I
just get on camera I'm like I put myself
up I was just jazzed up and that's what
I did naturally and people have liked it
and some you know and and I got fired up
from it too and so now I've done that
every morning and in my youtube channel
I did that on my recording on Wednesday
so like it's always testing right like
if somebody told me hey the secret to
success that was you gotta clap you know
before video to get jacked up I'm going
to feel awkward doing
it's not gonna go well but it's just it
came out it was instinctive and like
that you you resonate with it other
people resonate with it so I'm gonna
keep trying and doing it and that's
that's part of it that's part of the
mastery getting better who else comes on
and starts doing this thing it wasn't
you know intentional but that just came
out and you gotta run with it yeah maybe
i'm gonna start incorporating it in my
my podcast thing or something um have
you ever had like a video kind of just
take off cuz i know you like i was like
going through your like gallery and
you've had so many different light from
celebrities entrepreneurs like people
that have senior stuff your top 10 stuff
like you know you guys got vlogs on they
got the salsa videos right like have you
ever had like in the beginning or
somewhere just it kind of just took off
or was it did you find it was more of a
consistent consistency in growth I guess
um this actually ties well into the book
uh I had one video that took off that
became a huge video um and it was called
belief and this was a really important
time in my business where i was i was
making youtube videos they were getting
you know a couple hundred views i was
getting like one or two comments and for
me I'm like somebody commented man this
is amazing right like one person
comments it makes you feel on top of the
world I I understand you were starting
up I feel that that wasn't such a
distant future for me I feel the love of
getting one comment on the video it's
pretty special awesome and then I was I
was feeling it'll dissatisfied with my
business I didn't know I didn't know
what my purpose was I didn't know what
direction to take it I felt my message
was unclear and I came up with like I'm
about believe and if there's a whole
process to go through I believe
everybody has like one word that defines
who they are mine was believe it's what
the book is about and yeah the second
thing I did as a test as a believe text
in my business was I'm going to totally
change up my youtube channel and do one
video that's just about believe that was
totally different than all my other
videos before and that video lifted and
the previous video that I had the best
video I had ever was a hundred thousand
views and it took a year just over a
year to get
and that's pretty good hunter que pues I
was like that's a rockin video man this
will do it 100 k views in one month oh
my god it's just just destroyed and now
it's over a million views you know
trying to bump up to a couple million
hopefully so that was my first meeting
to take off and and I had that similar
success with everything else that I did
around belief which was around my one
word and so I outlined the process of
how i did that in the book and how other
people can do it for themselves but when
you have the self-awareness and when you
have the powerful mission that near now
like it gives you clarity on what you're
supposed to do that's when my channel
really started to explode so from that
moment on I had much more purpose and
much more intense and my audience really
resonated with it and that was a super
important moment in the the change of my
channel in my business well well that's
that's that's really really cool i read
up a little bit about kind of like the
backstory of the one word and you know
I've actually never done this but I I
posted this thing on my Instagram and
because I knew that we were having this
chat today and I said what is the one
word that you represent I'm just gonna
read you some of the comments I post
this like three hours ago so about 35
comments um you know so just going just
looking through it soul grit hustle
positivity passion excitement truth
relentless real so it's really amazing
because you know i'm looking through
this listen I'm like holy crap this is
like this is like an amazing just kind
of list of words and this is what people
represent why do you think it's so
important that people have like that one
word because most people don't know what
they stand for most people are living
other people's lives most people don't
really know what the direction is they
want to go in they may not be happy with
what they're doing right now but they
don't know where they need to go they
don't have the answer to get out in you
know the other way to think about it as
a core value and you look at all these
businesses that have core values like
here's our 10 core values like go talk
to the CEO of that business and see if
he actually knows what the core values
are and if you don't know what the core
values are how are you living them how
is this the lens through which you see
the world did you come up with one yeah
well I this is actually kind of a
follow-up question cuz yeah I pic
changemaker as one and then the second I
wrote it I was thinking well I don't
know like it's not like change maker
like you know there's a definition for
belief right there's your definition
there's like the dictionary's definition
so there's not like a real definition of
change maker which is actually something
I've asked all my guests on my show
before I kind of like as the last
question and so I was gonna ask you like
if I pick something that is a word that
you know that represents obviously my
brand but obviously I do genuinely
believe people that you know don't you
know that just like to kind of cause
trouble but in a really positive way
people that like the shift things up
people like the like to the shrub you
know to me that's what a change maker
means and it's what the whole show is
about people that are changing things
and creating their legacy creating their
brand so I was gonna ask you about that
actually mm-hmm so whether that's the
right word for you well I mean it's hard
to say right but like if I chose
something like change maker or do I have
to kind of you know go back maybe its
legacy all right or you know a word kind
of like you know where that really
resonates with me is it okay if it's a
word that's just part of my branding but
also you know heavily resonates with me
on a personal level sure so here's the
thing don't you don't want to take the
easy way out like it's convenient to
pick changemaker right don't do it just
for marketing right I can meet in
something else and it may mean you re
brand and then that becomes an even more
powerful thing that you can shoot off to
so it's easy to stay with the girlfriend
that you know you're just getting good
along with cigarette you don't want to
break up you're right there's someone
better out there for you but it's too
scary a road to go down right so like
only you can answer that question that's
really but just it's too important a
question to be stuck in the wrong thing
for the rest of your life there is a
common definition and then you get to
add your own definition to it so believe
most people think believe in yourself is
self-confidence
that's quite believable all right for me
it's also believe in what you're doing
this is the passion for your work right
and the third part is believe it's going
to work out and have the conviction and
persistence to follow through so that
I'll make that change is believed in to
hashtag believe for me and so if it
let's run with changemaker as an example
what is that what does that break down
to for you so there might be the common
definition that most people think of but
then you're adding some you're adding
some g wong in there on the other two
sides to write to make it your your
credo which we figure out the three
things that break up your one word then
everything you do has to fit within
these categories and it can be direction
for what you're doing like so when
you're looking at okay there's the
branding the marketing co aids in it's
in the name of your show awesome you
know does modern day have to be in there
is that is that part of what you're all
about or not the guests that you filter
through have to be about making change
somehow right you're not going to have
some boring corporate CEO on even though
you might be some huge big name but it
doesn't embody the characteristics right
ah you know the the logo that you have I
haven't seen the local what is it is it
around that doesn't make me want to go
and create some change right the the
tagline the colors that you're using
they all have meaning the people that
you bring on right so you're the guy in
front of the microphone and so you know
asking questions but as you build this
thing up you're going to need a team
you're going to need producers and
website developers and all these people
you don't want to hire just a website
developer you need to hire the rebel
website in melbourne right or the what
what I've gotta get it is our right the
changemaker website developer and he's
only going to care about you because
you're on the same path because you're
off trying to do something insane that
nobody else is doing and so if you don't
have that powerful mission you're just
another podcaster and and he's just
another website developer and you're
going to track just people who are
coders and that's great but it's not
going to help you get to where you need
to go so understanding the mission that
you're on and have
it really means something and then
articulating it helps yeah but it helps
attract the right people but also helps
your audience spread the message for you
right so you have to listen to this show
because it's about making change or
whatever it is right people everything
that I do is around believe even this I
believe in I believe in a better version
of j wang and that's why I'm so fired up
is because I want your podcast to rock
it and I believe that as good as you are
now you could crush if you focus on a
couple things to get better well and so
everything believe pumps through my
veins and it is who I am and it's
everything I do that is about belief has
exploded and everybody does their thing
some people know right away I didn't
actually I didn't know right away but
some people know it right away how'd you
figure it out uh if people are listening
to this and they're like wow it sounds
great you know leverage jade has his own
thoughts evan is a super bot in his
whole team is like believe how do you
figure it out yeah well I mean that's
what the book is all about okay that's
the process but but it's divided into
core campaign and company and cores just
you figuring out what you're all about
there's a couple ways to do it and you
get this helps share with yours too you
think about everything that makes you
happy and it ever has makes you happy
like who are the best interviews that
you had on or who do you really wish you
can get on your show like if I think of
a changemaker I think of I think of jobs
I think of Elon Musk you know that's to
be your lens oh like who are the guys
that man i really want them on my show
or the people you've really enjoyed a
lot what kind of songs do you like to
listen to who are your best friends you
know what teacher really pushed you and
motivated you all the things that make
you happy they're connected from a
common theme and it's a constant it's
not something that oh yeah next year I
don't care about change you know I'm
going to be mr. played safe right like
it's gotta be something that has always
been with you and always will be with
you it's a constants not a new year's
resolution that this year I'm going to
change more right it's it's just like
part of your DNA so some people get it
just by that positive
stations with all the happy things that
make you come alive and there's no like
the music I like may not be the music
you like you know it's fine some people
find it by going negative like so you
can't find am I going positive who are
the one of the things you hate or the
people that you hain't right like I hate
you know if it's for me it's putting
people down and telling telling people
that they can't do something just me
nuts now on top potential does me nuts
nuts like somebody has all this
potential in them when they're not doing
anything about it I will have a heart
attack right this is like 80 belief for
me so you know who are the people that
you can't stand being around you know if
it's changing my think of the people
like oh we've always done it this way or
something like that right like if that
kind of person drives you absolutely
bonkers then that's you know you're
getting closer so all the negative
things and then try to find the opposite
to find what it is that you are all
about and once you get that clear you
man things things take off um so so you
got cords about finding your one word
campaign isn't about really marketing
your business I start with my newsletter
and then I move to my youtube channel
and testing it out how to market
yourself now round your one word and
then company is about building a
business everything from a
fifty-thousand-dollar business to a half
a million million five million and 150
million from hiring and firing and
raising capital in all the operations of
running the company but it's it's yeah
well Evan I mean I first of all I love
how fired up you are because I hope
people are watching this and they're
like trying to go through this process
themselves or they can take one of your
book bundles which I looked at and was
really cool because that whole negative
bitty thing even though it kind of
sounds negative sometimes a lot actually
a lot easier I don't know what my
passion is Oh what isn't your passion
you know what do you hate what is it
definitely not right I love that you
pointed out um last couple questions for
you like as your building i mean the
book the show your building all these
diff
you know piece of content is really kind
of like a belief movement you know this
this like whole tribe that you know
believes what you believe is not part of
your legacy is that is that how you view
it like when it's all done and said like
how do you kind of envision your own
legacy um it's an interesting question
uh I mean my bigger term goal is to I
want to be able to help a billion
entrepreneurs and and reaching that
exact number is the goal but doing
things at scale is the goal doing things
it's the reason for writing the book
instead of helping people one-on-one I
want to be able to reach lots of people
um I would love you know I believe that
all the world's problems can be solved
by entrepreneurs it's what I
fundamentally believe it's not going to
be the government's it doesn't matter if
Clinton or chump wins you know it's not
going to be a you know the the big firms
it's not going to be the big companies i
save us it's y entre preneur all of the
major problems from health care to world
peace you know solving cancer is going
to be the entrepreneurs who are being
creative and awesome and doing their
thing we are the ones who are going to
solve all the problems in the world and
so I see myself as having the unique
ability to help entrepreneurs believe in
themselves to go and do those big scary
things to see somebody with untapped
potential who's wood plane way smaller
than they should yeah and helping them
get to that point where they're having a
big impact and so what I'm trying to
focus more and more my time on is trying
to spread the message to a lot of people
trying to help them believe in
themselves and their crazy ideas for a
lot of people I'm the only like my
youtube channel i don't know them
personally but right my youtube channel
is the only thing that's positive in
their life the only thing that makes
them believe in themselves because their
parents and their friends and the people
around them say that's stupid that's
never going to work like go back to
mcdonalds and be that cashier or
whatever at sassi right thing is easy to
see they throw right yeah and so I see
that as a responsibility of mine to go
out and try
have that big impact and touch people's
lives um the YouTube channel is working
i hope the book is working too there's a
lot of love that was put into that um
and so I think I mean I'm still a young
guy I'm 36 years old I got a I got a lot
of years to live and I don't know what
I'm going to be doing when I'm 50 let
alone when I'm 38 but hopefully doing
something that has a big impact is
something that really motivates me well
I think everyone it's um I think was
Peter diamantis he says when you were
trying to kind of attack the world's
biggest problems right that's when
people can really kind of buy into the
vision that you really paint right Elon
Musk people love him and you know
chances are i mean he's painting a you
know a picture where you know people can
go to Mars it's the idea that people
it's like how big he's thinking that
people are like oh my god this is so
massive and this is so amazing it's not
you know we might not see it in this
lifetime or in his lifetime or what have
you but it's the idea that it could
happen right and so I think anytime
people here that's level of big thinking
like what a lot of the stuff they just
said um you know that's that's kind of
you know super motivating and inspiring
before we wrap up on my last question
which you kind of already know um tell
us a little bit about the book and where
people can go because you've got some
pretty cool stuff going on with your
book bundles if people want to figure
out there one word I think you know you
have a really great framework around
that sure it's Emma calm calm Evan
Carmichael calm eisler sometimes / one
word all lower case no dashes or
anything one word um the basic book
comes with a whole bunch of free bonuses
and downloads and you know I can get a
shout out of my youtube channel and some
free self promotion if you guys have
websites or something that you want to
link up there's bundles so if you buy
ten copies you get something if you buy
you know 100 copies you get selfless as
you work your way up everything from
asking me a question I make a video
response to you up to me coaching you
and helping you with your business and
get into the next step so tons of
options over there it
drops on december six but the bonuses
you get immediately and then you get the
book when it comes out december six i
want i want people to read it and apply
it and and that's what I'm that's what
I'm like everybody I've walked through
the process has insane changes in their
life in their business and so I want to
do that at scale I want I'm telling
people to read it and then go off and
make big changes in what they're doing
to I want you to embrace it man I want
you to embrace like what is so what I
want J Wong's thing to explode and so
like if you could give people better
direction and you you figured out
exactly what you're all about um man
like the potential you're asking great
questions you could you could destroy it
well I love that you're thinking about I
literally i mentioned i watch the you
know just the last part of urine grants
interview any mention like you know
eighty-four percent or something like
that of books don't get read mhmmm and
so I love that when its tactical you
know I think it's really great to kind
of go you know mindset like like why are
we doing what we're doing but then to
get really kind of in in in the in the
dirt of it and say okay how do we
tactically figure this out how do we
apply it and how do we see that result
right right because we both know
consuming content is just like the first
thing it's like the easy first thing you
know and a lot of people don't even do
that um so what appointment and it's so
many things it's everything like your
physical environment man all of this is
believed for me right yeah like the
people on the wall are chosen here you
may hate Steve Jobs at Howard Schultz
that's cool man that means something to
me look at your space like that painting
behind the wall with that cushion next
to you or you know the shirt that you're
wearing does that make you I feel like
that man every time I get on and wear
this shirt right like there's it's with
purpose right like okay you're on a
mission your time is limited you gotta
go and crush so the clothes you wear the
things on your wall like does it make
you feel like you're unstoppable
changemaker right when you get back
clarity everything starts to change yeah
well by the way painting is Muhammad Ali
I don't know if people can see you love
it man
like that's that's what it's got to be
right the belief system that you are the
greatest that you are the best Evan man
it's it's been such an awesome
conversation last question for you I
already gonna ask that though what's
your definition like what comes to mind
when you first heard of the word change
maker that's a good question uh yeah ask
it I ask it every every guess just so I
can get some work Sarah Tiana to be
honest yeah so here's the thing this
might be this might be against this
might get me some hate with your
audience I didn't I didn't think of
anything when I first thought it like
when I saw the name how to become a
modern day change maker yeah I didn't
think of anything I thought maybe the
name was long but if I think about it
like about you're trying to accomplish
in have having that big impact what is
what is that like rebel or what is that
person is off at somebody who is
unsatisfied with the status quo like
that's what I kind of get from the vibe
that you're putting out and what I would
also think about unsatisfied with the
status quo unhappy with unreached
potential someone who wants to not just
complain about the situation but go out
and make it better right the Mahatma
Gandhi be the change you want to see
right stop complaining about why this is
it go out and do something about it
that's a change maker I think in the
apple commercial the what was the apple
commercial the better to be different
one yeah yeah rebels the then ready I
forget all the words that is quote yeah
I mean it's really great if what people
want to look it up that's what I think
when you say that that's what I think of
and so actually thinking that that's my
first reaction I think I think man you
have a huge opportunity to make what
you're all about super powerful mmm you
know Evan first of all I appreciate the
honesty of just like saying exactly what
came to your mind even it was nothing um
but yeah I
you know chatting with you and getting a
chance to you know have I always say
like having I'm sure you think this to I
don't know actually but in thinking and
putting together all the content that
you do don't you think it's kind of like
a hack to the world because you get to
access literally people that are alive
and you get to pick their brains about
everything and the world you know top
experts on all these things but you also
get you study a lot of probably
biographies and you know 15 hours of
Elon Musk condensed in the whatever 15
minutes right so it's like a huge hack
that goes back to one of your points of
all these kids that are they have access
to all of this like so abundantly
inflated percent is that their
fingertips and now it's really just up
to them or up to whoever is watching
this or listening those whatever it is
it's up to you to really do something
with it I have a guy who's full-time job
it is to research these things and he's
doing all the work and then my three
editors put it together for you like
it's for me I would do it anyway I need
it like it's changed my life but it's
for for you guys to enjoy for free and I
hope people do and and they don't need
to watch every video like consuming
alone doesn't help make me happy go out
to your point like right at the top of
the show consume what you need and then
go out and take some action yeah do not
super pump for you like yeah big
questions you got an awesome vibe i
think i think the podcasting thing man
like it could really explode for you
well and and we both live in toronto so
all right are you drunk i know that dude
we got to do something together yeah man
we gotta do something like live I don't
know which which area sit here in but
i'm in north york and every wednesday
afternoon we film at my dance studio at
close to yonge and sheppard between step
in and finish so i'm just at midtown
young and Eggman okay look so take this
offline the one usually will get this
off my mom I'm youtube channel get ready
for some jwong explosion on the channel
sometime soon Evan where can people
socially stalk you all right are you
great thanks new tubes the best worst
kind of like the hub yeah YouTube the
best place i'm on twitter i still
respond personal twitter not
that active on Facebook and stuff so
youtube or Twitter YouTube to get the
best stuff though yeah that's kept us
way too much it's too prolific but
that's awesome Evan thank you so much
for spending the time with us I know you
gotta get off and you get you it was a
full day of interviews for you so it's
still good to see that you're I'm gonna
let you do your clapping ritual whatever
you gotta do behind the scenes by the
man slow appreciate it hey long
everybody jay long whoo all right thanks
bro we'll talk soon I meant cheers